guys um for those of you that know I
live in Nashville and what's been going
on here today
um
my kids go to school right next to a
school where there was a shooting today
and um we moved here from Connecticut
where we were in a school a little ways
down from Sandy Hook so this is our
second experience with a school shooting
with our kids being a close proximity
luckily we are all okay but we did my
husband and I were on our way to school
for conferences and uh luckily our kids
weren't in today and uh we helped a
class of kindergartners across a busy
highway that were climbing out of the
woods that were trying to escape
the shooter situation at their school so
we helped all these tiny little little
kids across the road and get their
teachers over there and we helped a mom
reunite with her children and um
I just I I don't know what to say
anymore it is just enough is enough and
um
just pray pray for the families